[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit gundula
gause und claus kleber
guten abend das ist eine sehr
eigenartige politische lage in berlin
morgen soll im bundestag die mehrheit
der abgeordneten der eigentlich ja noch
gar nicht existierenden ampel koalition
ein gesetz beschließen dass staatliches
handeln in der aktuell größten krise des
landes neu regelt pandemie die
handlungsmöglichkeiten der noch
kanzlerin birken auf appelle reduziert
klaus brodbeck berichtet man darf das
wohl eine mahnung nennen kann alle seit
tagen in der debatte eher zurückhaltend
nur noch geschäftsführend im amt die
pandemie aber heftiger denn je die noch
kanzlerin kritisiert die pläne der ampel
parteien aber nicht nur die den virus
ist es vollkommen egal ob deutschland
sich gerade in einer phase mit
geschäftsführender bundesregierung die
ich führe und verhandlungen zur bildung
einer neuen bundesregierung befindet
einziges kriterium unserer beratung und
zwar gerade morgen auch bei der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz hat deshalb
zu sein was jetzt mitten in der vierten
welle gegen das aktuelle dramatische
infektionsgeschehen in deutschland zu
tun ist und was nicht
angesprochen wohl auch
nrw-ministerpräsident hendrik wüst
zugleich vorsitzende der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
bezeichnet per brief mit datum von
gestern die neuen maßnahmen der ampel
als nicht ausreichend und droht das
gesetz im bundesrat zu stoppen es sei so
nicht zustimmungsfähig den ländern wird
ein bewährtes instrumentarium
zumindestens sehr sehr stark
eingeschränkt auf eine neue
rechtsgrundlage gestellt und insofern
ist das natürlich auch brandgefährlich
was da jetzt gemacht wird von der ampel
deren vertreter aber geben sich heute
zuversichtlich bis gelassen wir haben
jetzt seit beginn der pandemie im
frühjahr des letzten jahres alles
gemeinsam gemacht und uns
sehr viel untergehakt und keine
parteipolitischen manöver
durchgeführt ich glaube das sollte auch
bis zum ende so bleiben was es nicht
mehr gibt sind in der regel maßnahmen
die auch in der vergangenheit ihre
wirksamkeit nicht bewiesen haben wie
beispielsweise
pauschale ausgangssperren noch immer
ausstehen eine offizielle empfehlung der
ständigen impfkommission für booster
impfungen schon ab 18 jahren die
eigentlich für heute erwartet wurde ja
auch das eine mahnung
chuck unterlag kann es sein dass dieser
gesetzentwurf morgen durch feld und die
pandemie vorschriften des bundes nächste
woche einfach irgendwie auslaufen so
morgen wenn das gesetz im bundestag
beraten wird wird wahrscheinlich relativ
schnell gehen denn da hat die haben die
ampel koalition ihrer die möglichen
ampelkoalition ehre eine mehrheit die
werden dazu wohl ja sagen übermorgen ist
der entscheidende tag am freitag da muss
der bundesrat zustimmen und da kann die
union ihre drohung wahr machen indem sie
nämlich nicht ja sagt zu diesem gesetz
sie müsste explizit ja sagen wenn sie
sich enthält dann ist das wie ein nein
zu werten und dann wäre dieses gesetz im
bundesrat durchgefallen es würde folgen
ein mehrstufiges verfahren indem man das
ganze theoretisch noch retten könnte im
bundestag mit nachverhandlungen
aber da sagt uns die
bundestagsverwaltung heute dazu aus
verschiedenen gründen ist das sehr
schwierig und sehr knapp bemessen die
zeit also das könnte auch sein dass dann
dieses gesetz tatsächlich scheitert und
heute nacht wird jetzt nicht beraten
oder morgen früh noch im bundestag man
einigt sich dann doch auf was ist das im
moment das ziel das ist die große frage
dann müsste die union mit tatsächlichen
konkreten forderungen noch einmal auf
die ampel zu gehen das was wir heute
hier gehört haben klingt nicht danach
also aktuell haben wir von keinen
laufenden verhandlungen gehört und man
hat ja auch in den öffentlichen
statements der union heute keine
expliziten forderungen gehört was
konkret sie dann genauer verbessert
haben möchte sie hat nur gesagt es
reicht eben nicht aus und das ist ganz
offensichtlich eine kraftprobe in der
sie auch einmal zeigt wie sie ihre macht
ausspielen kann im bundesrat die frage
ist natürlich ob das günstig ist und wie
das wirkt in einer solchen situation in
der es um die panne nie geht was man
ganz klar sagen kann ist dass sie hier
auf einen anderen stil in der opposition
setzt als ihre vorgänger gemacht haben
da haben nämlich im verlaufe der
pandemie fdp und grüne in der opposition
doch hin und wieder auch dinge
zugestimmt mit denen sie eigentlich
nicht so ganz einverstanden gewesen sind
mal gucken wie das spiel dann morgen
ausgeht wir werden einander viel
verzeihen müssen das hat jens spahn noch
ziemlich am anfang von pandemie und
maßnahmen prophezeit und diese seine
ahnung hat nie aufgehört sich zu
bestätigen auch welle nummer vier könnte
sich jetzt nicht derart auftürmen ohne
millionenfachen individuellen leichtsinn
und massive politische versäumnisse wahr
ist aber schon auch dass ein neues virus
immer unerwartete lektion erteilt was
zum beispiel der schutz aus der impfung
in der del-tabelle so viel schneller
nachlässt als erwartet das weiß man
natürlich erst dann wenn es soweit ist
neue erkenntnisse verändern nur mal den
blick auf den impfschutz er ist schon
noch da und wesentlich aber weiter als
gedacht entfernt von perfekter
sicherheit das heißt auch geimpfte
müssen vorsichtig bleiben vor allem im
interesse von anderen warum erklärt
christian von rechenberg
zwei impfungen das war's schuldigkeit
getan ab in die freiheit dachten wir
dann kam delta ansteckender robuster
ideal angepasst an eine noch nicht
ausreichend geschützte bevölkerung delta
hat die lage verändert
auch für vollständig geimpft und
genießen
man muss auch immer mal ganz klar sagen
diesen winter müssen auch die geimpften
noch einmal etwas disziplin halten das
heißt auch als geimpfte muss man
realisieren dass man ansteckend sein
kann unbemerkt neue studien aus england
lassen aufhorchen sie zeigen dass
geimpfte mit impf durchbrüchen unter
umständen eine ähnlich hohe viruslast
haben können wie ungeimpfte allerdings
im vergleich in einem viel kürzeren
zeitraum heißt die impfung macht eine
weitergabe des virus schwierige
aber eben nicht unmöglich
wie stark dieser schutz vor der
weitergabe ist hängt aber auch davon ab
wie lange meine zweite impfung her ist
das heißt er war am anfang mal relativ
gut und da hat man einen 80 oder 90
prozentigen schutz vor der weitergabe
gehabt jetzt gibt es studien die sagen
der schutz ist nur noch 60 prozent
andere studien die sagen ist es gerade
mal so gut 30 prozent das heißt man gibt
es immer noch weniger weiter als ein
nicht geimpfter aber der unterschied
nimmt immer weiter ab und dass abhängig
von alter begleiterkrankung oder dem
impfstoff nach relativ kurzer zeit
diese studien aufzeigen dass circa drei
monate nach kollision
diese schutzwirkung übertragung bei
astrazeneca im prinzip nicht mehr
vorhanden ist und bei uns sechs
schrittweise untergeht und das ist
glaube ich dass sie letztlich auch sehr
sehr wesentliche argumente für die
auffrischungsimpfungen die ergebnisse
unterstreichen die wichtigkeit dieser
auffrischungsimpfung für genesene und
geimpfte bringen ein zeitfenster ins
spiel offen inwieweit dieses künftig
eine rolle spielt zudem zeigen die
studien auch wie zentral zweig plus
werden könnte also die pflicht wird die
impfte und genießen er sich zusätzlich
zu testen maske zu tragen abstand zu
halten auch wenn es nervt
wir müssen versuchen
jede
maßnahme die in form darstellen und
realisierbar ist dass wir die zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt auch nützen weil die
spitäler füllen sich und das ist
absehbar dass die demnächst voll sein
werden allerdings einige experten mahnen
dass ein flächendeckendes testen für
alle menschen kaum realisierbar ist
tests im privaten und im umfeld
verletzlicher gruppen ja ansonsten
sollte die energie in eine strategie
fließen nicht in viele
das allerwichtigste ist dass wir die
lücke schließen und das wusstet wird das
ist das einzige was wirklich nachhaltig
wirkt alles andere sind ja
überbrückungsmaßnahmen die sind jetzt
aus der not geboren weil wenn ich früher
angefangen haben damit die fallzahlen
wirklich wieder runtergehen das wissen
aus der erfahrung aus israel würde es
zum beispiel helfen 50 prozent der
menschen zu ostern da kann sich mit
seiner booster impfung gerade bei den
jüngeren waren auch von den instanzen
hier aus einer welle rausnehmen fazit
die impfung schützt und ist elementar im
kampf gegen korona und doch sollten sich
geimpfte und genießen nicht zurücklehnen
sondern ihren impfschutz soweit nötig
und empfohlen auffrischen und bis dahin
aufpassen auf sich und die menschen um
sie herum
also praktisch heißt das geimpft oder
genesen sein allein schützt nicht genug
besonders nicht die anderen menschen
denen man begegnet wer jetzt noch zweig
genießen oder geimpft als alleinigen
sicheren weg preist der ist nicht mehr
auf dem aktuellen stand zweig braucht
ergänzung auffrischung masken abstand
und da wo es ganz eng wird einen
aktuellen sorgfältig gemachten test es
ist halt nicht vorbei bevor es vorbei
ist das heißt aber auch dass der stress
weiter geht während die geduldsfaden
schon auslaufen und nerven blank liegen
das hat auch messbare folgen die heute
die herbsttagung des bundeskriminalamtes
beschäftigten es gibt auch spürbare
folgen über die stefanie groß berichtet
in dem fall aus berlin
berlin die sonst so unangepasste
hauptstadt setzt zweig relativ
diszipliniert um kino kultur
kulinarisches nur für geimpfte oder
genesene finden die meisten richtig die
korona politik nicht die wut aber er
lies
wir werden gerade so ein bisschen
politisch instrumentalisiert so fühlt
sich zumindest an weil das was irgendwie
den gesamten sommer über nicht
funktioniert hat irgendwie die leute
dazu bewegen sich zu impfen wird jetzt
gerade versucht über eine zweig
regelungen durchzusetzen und und bleibt
dadurch umsätze werke im sankt oberholz
wiederum einen kaffee mit workspace für
hipster arbeiten die jungen für ihre
zukunft im alltag erleben sie durch
corona bröckelt der zusammenhalt ich
glaube schon dass die pandemie die
gesellschaft gespalten hat es mit
freunden die einfach zum beispiel nicht
15 jetzt nichts mehr unternehmen können
die krisen der letzten jahrzehnte
stressen die gesellschaft nachhaltig
finanzkrise flüchtlingskrise corona
krise führten zur vertrauenskrise und
zur abspaltung einiger gruppen besonders
im osten hier kommt das trauma der
diktatur hinzu ein drängendes problem
wie eine neue studie an der universität
halle wittenberg belegt mit diesen neuen
spaltungen die jetzt aufgebrochen sind
da muss man einen weg finden wie man mit
diesen spaltungen sinnvoll umgeht wenn
sie nur ausgrenzen will wenn man nur
denkt man sitzt das problem aus wie man
das problem nicht lösen und es wird sich
über die zeit verschärfen
die wut die aggressionen der sogenannten
corona leutner und impfgegner entlädt
sich immer wieder sichtbar auf der
straße die polarisierte gesellschaft
thema der heutigen tagung des
bundeskriminalamtes
die polizei hat die große aufgabe darauf
zu achten dass die regeln auch
eingehalten werden und das merken wir
gerade sehr sehr genau diese
polarisierung zwischen den einzelnen
lagern wenn sie dazwischen stehen auf
der straße in einer demonstrativen lage
oder wenn sie die aktuellen regeln
durchsetzen dann bekommen sie natürlich
genau das ab aber nicht nur vor ort
sondern auch wenn sie daran denken wie
die die zahl der politisch motivierten
kriminalität
zunimmt auch im ärzte oder virologen wie
martin stürmer werden im netz beleidigt
angefeindet manchmal schwappt der hass
sogar bis vor die haustür wenn es dann
so ist wie bei uns einmal mit dem zaun
wenn der zaun tatsächlich geschmiert
wird dann ist man sehr nahe kommt das
ganze sehr nahe und da sind die
diskussion auch im familienkreis doch
schon sehr intensiv die pandemie
hinterlässt in der gesellschaft ihre
spuren die mehrheit bleibt solidarisch
einige die sich abgespalten haben
radikalisieren sich
was jetzt am besten ton fragt na sein
könnte mir den regierenden bürgermeister
von berlin michael müller im update um
0.45 und nachrichten jetzt von kunden
aus
bundeskanzlerin merkel hat wegen der
migranten krise an der polnisch
russischen grenze mit polens
ministerpräsident mohammed telefoniert
sowie erneut mit belarus machthaber
lukaschenko dabei habe merkel eine
humanitäre versorgung und rückkehr
möglichkeiten der betroffenen gefordert
erklärte regierungssprecher seibert nach
angaben aus minsk ging es auch um
direkte verhandlungen zwischen der eu
und belarus an einem ersten telefonat
vorgestern hatte es teils heftige kritik
gegeben da die eu lukaschenko nicht als
präsidenten anerkennt an der grenze zu
polen haben die weißrussischen behörden
damit begonnen
migranten in leer lagerhallen zu bringen
zugleich stellte die eben 700.000 euro
für die menschen dort zur verfügung
im rennen um den parteivorsitz der cdu
ist um 18 uhr die bewerbungsfrist
abgelaufen
demnach sind wie bekannt von ihren
kreisverbänden ordnungsgemäß nominiert
der geschäftsführende kanzleramtschef
helge braun der frühere fraktionschef
friedrich merz und der außenpolitiker
norbert röttgen eine cdu politikerin aus
brandenburg hatte noch versucht sich von
ihrem kreisverband nominieren zu lassen
erhielt aber keine zustimmung
in washington ist nach dem sturm auf das
kapitol im januar einer der daran
beteiligten zu knapp dreieinhalb jahren
haft verurteilt worden jacob schänzli
selbsternannte schamane und anhänger der
kanon bewegung war zu einem der
bekanntesten gesichter des angriffs
geworden im januar hatte er gemeinsam
mit anderen trump anhängern gewaltsam
das capitol gestürmt dabei waren fünf
menschen ums leben gekommen janes ley
habe die menge besonders angestachelt so
der richter
auf die not von millionen menschen die
in afghanistan hunger leiden machen
hilfsorganisationen aufmerksam infolge
mehrerer dürren und nach der
machtergreifung durch die taliban wird
die situation der zivilbevölkerung immer
schwieriger die wirtschaft ist
zusammengebrochen die
weltgesundheitsorganisation warnt vor
einer hungersnot bis zu 19 millionen
menschen in afghanistan sind auf
lebensmittelhilfen angewiesen
das ist fast die hälfte der
gesamtbevölkerung des landes wenn sie
den menschen in afghanistan helfen
wollen dann ist das über spenden möglich
an das aktionsbündnis katastrophenhilfe
bahn.de
65 104 106 100 104 106 100 stichwort zdf
nothilfe aufgabe
nicht alles was unerwartet kommt muss
schlimm seien nicht mal bei corona als
unsere gesundheitssysteme auf der
hochentwickelten nordhalbkugel der erde
in der pandemie an ihre grenzen kamen da
mochte man gar nicht daran denken was
sie in den armen ländern afrikas
anrichten würde anfangs kamen dann aus
den großen bevölkerungszentren auch
genau die schrecklichen bilder wie man
befürchten musste heute berichtet unsere
afrika korrespondentin von einer
unerwarteten wendung der geschichte die
immer wieder grausam geprüften menschen
und gesellschaften afrikas zeigen ihre
widerstandskraft gewachsen in krisen
katastrophen und notlagen die europa
lange erspart geblieben sind
es sind bilder von denen sie auf
deutschen intensivstationen derzeit nur
träumen können und sie kommen aus afrika
leere betten verwaiste gänge entspanntes
arbeiten lineas größte corona station
steht in nairobi hospital aufgebaut mit
hilfe der un
135 betten gibt es nur drei sind belegt
wie kann das sein gerade erst war der
leiter der station auf einem pathologen
kongress im mittelpunkt die auswertung
einer studie von blutproben von
schwangeren und spendern
man fand heraus dass sich viele menschen
bereits mit dem virus in kontakt
gekommen waren und antikörper hatten am
ende der dritten welle waren es sogar 68
prozent und wenn man das auf die dritte
welle überträgt glaube ich dass jemand
mit dem ausbruch des virus an für afrika
horrorszenarien vorausgesagt worden eine
hohe bevölkerungsdichte
erbärmliche wohn und hygiene
verhältnisse gerade in den slums das
virus würde sich rasant verbreiten hieß
es zumindest das hat es offenbar doch
nur wenige haben es anscheinend gemerkt
ich glaube nicht dass die leute wo ich
wohne corona hatten ich denke sie hatten
einfach nur eine erkältung
hatte eine laufende nase ich wusste
nicht was los ist ich bin mit ihm ins
krankenhaus aber ich habe ihn nicht auf
probe testen lassen der epidemie olo
geäußerten lehre forscht mit anderen für
die washington state university auch in
der rubys größten slum kibera die korona
sterblichkeit so seine studie liegt in
kenia 20 mal niedriger als in europa mit
bing wir wo wir denken dass die menschen
in der vergangenheit antikörper gebildet
haben aus anderen infektionen die
wahrscheinlich einer kurve infektion
ähneln wir glauben dass diese antikörper
eine kreuzreaktion auslösen könnten weil
sie kurven ähneln und die bevölkerung
vor schweren formen von kuwait schützen
können
hinzu kommt in kenia liegt das
durchschnittsalter unter 20 jahre viele
junge haben die krankheit leichter
weggesteckt weil schnell oder gar pcr
tests in kenia sehr teuer sind bleiben
sie lieber zu hause anstatt sich zum
arzt zu begeben die meisten menschen
fürchten sich vor der isolation und
davor in kliniken zu gehen natürlich kam
sie erst als die krankheit einen anderen
verlauf genommen hatte wenn sie also in
die einrichtung kamen waren sie bereits
schwer krank die wissenschaftler
vermuten dass china bald eine
herdenimmunität haben könnte es wäre ein
glücksfall in einem land in dem die
impfquote immer noch bei vier prozent
liegt doch die experten warnen auch es
könnten gerade in afrika neue stämme von
lars koch 2 auftreten und menschen sich
neu infizieren
unterdessen macht auch die
pharmazeutische forschung in dem thema
fortschritt in der eu könnte es
demnächst einen weiteren corona
impfstoff gegen der us-hersteller nowaks
hat für seinen tod impfstoff eine
zulassung in der eu beantragt das mittel
setzt auf die traditionelle methode mit
abgetöteten bestandteilen des corona
virus um das menschliche immunsystem zu
aktivieren und könnte damit auf
interesse bei denjenigen stoßen die
vorbehalte gegen mrsa vakzine oder
vector impfstoffe haben die
spitzenorganisationen des deutschen
einzelhandels der handelsverband hde
lehnt trotz steigender infektionszahlen
hierzulande weitere corona maßnahmen in
den läden wie 2g oder 3g ab und setzt
weiter auf das tragen von masken die
sorgen der branche sind groß auch bei
einer weiteren verschuldung der
innenstädte frank bethmann der
handelsverband schlägt alarm ebenso wie
der deutsche städtetag ja der
handelsverband war es natürlich zu genau
was die stunde geschlagen hat schärfere
beschränkungen jetzt im
weihnachtsgeschäft werden ein echter
umsatz killer und träfen viele
ladenbesitzer doppelt denn sie kämpfen
zudem ja auch damit dass ware gar nicht
kommt technische produkte aber auch
spielzeug fahrräder oder kleidung sind
teilweise nicht lieferbar und das bis
nach weihnachten
und diese lieferengpässe wirkten sich
aus 60 prozent der deutschen händler
erwarten zumindest leichte einbußen
immerhin 20 prozent gehen von deutlichen
umsatzeinbußen aus die vierte welle
stellt daher nicht nur den einzelhandel
vor große herausforderungen erste
weihnachtsmärkte werden abgesagt
marktkaufleute und restaurantbesitzer
kämpfen erneut um ihre existenz und mit
ihnen kämpfen die innenstädte um ihre
attraktivität auf dem städtetag in
erfurt deshalb heute die forderung an
die neue bundesregierung die mittel
gegen die verödung vieler innenstädte
deutlich aufzustocken wir brauchen 500
millionen euro pro jahr über die
nächsten fünf jahre sagt burkhard jung
präsident des deutschen städtetages für
unattraktive stadtzentren ist sicher
nicht allein die pandemie verantwortlich
zu machen doch einmal mehr wird durch
bewohner deutlich wo dringender
handlungsbedarf besteht frank bethmann
vielen dank
die eu kommission will mit einem neuen
gesetz gegen illegale und auch legale
waldrodung vorgehen außerdem solle
strengere regeln für abfall exporte
geben zum schutz der regenwälder sollen
etwa soja oder palmöl aus plantagen auf
neu gerodeten fläche nicht mehr in die
europäische union importiert werden
dürfen laut eu kommission wurden
zwischen 1990 und 2020 weltweit rund 420
millionen hektar wald zerstört eine
fläche größer als die eben
fehlen noch die gewinnzahlen vom lotto
am mittwoch sie lauten ohne gewähr 5 15
21 25
28 47 superzahl 9 weitere gewinnzahlen
auf lotto zdf de und im zdf text
im theater am schiffbauerdamm dem
magischen platz in der mitte von berlin
wirkstätte von berthold brecht kurt
weill und lotte lenya feiert heute ein
mann seinen 85 geburtstag der dort mal
angefangen und dann nie mehr aufgehört
hat aufrührer und störer zu sein wolf
biermann war als jugendlicher mit seiner
mutter nach dem krieg aus hamburg nach
ost berlin gegangen sie gehörten zu
denen die überzeugt waren dass
antifaschismus und glaube an die ddr
untrennbar sein und dann konnte diese
ddr mit diesem eigenwilligen
buchstäblich immer theater machenden
nicht auf linie zu bringen den vorteilen
platzenden man nichts anfassen das
politbüro der sed beschloss
hochoffiziell seine ausbürgerung und
dann geschah erstaunlich ist da raffte
sich zum ersten mal
die kulturelle elite des arbeiter- und
bauernstaates zu widerstand auf christa
wolf jurek becker sarah kirsch stefan
heym und viele andere protestierten
heute vor 45 jahren öffentlich gegen
diesen beschluss und da hat etwas
begonnen hat das politbüro einen
grundstein gelegt für das was 13 jahre
später die mauer stürzte es gibt ein
großes leben zu feiern stephan merz
rad-verband unser land ein
[Musik]
wolf biermann am abend im berliner
ensemble
erinnerungen kommen hoch unausweichlich
die weidendammer brücke ist gleich um
die ecke mit den preußen adler der
ikarus ist eines der letzten lieder das
biermann in ost-berlin komponiert hat
1976 bevor die ddr ihn rausgeschmissen
hat er wollte es nicht verlassen dass
insel land mit rad verband
ich wollte aber gerne hier bleiben weil
ich hier meine vertrauten freunde das
ist klar wie robert havemann wie jürgen
fuchs aber auch meine vertrauten feinde
auf der ich gut trainiert war
1953 kam der sohn eines im kz ermordeten
jüdischen kommunisten aus hamburg nach
ost berlin am berliner ensemble wird er
zwei jahre lang regieassistent von
intendantin und brecht witwe helene
weigel er wird dichter und liedermacher
dann sed ausschluss und berufsverbot
das heißt mit liedern mit starken
gedichten kann man sich sehr wohl
einmischen entscheid der welt das habe
ich dann erfahren dass
sich nicht
doch biermann arbeitet weiter schreibt
gedichte nimmt platten auf empfängt west
fernsehen die aufnahmen werden in den
westen geschmuggelt und erscheinen dort
seine legendäre wohnung in der
chausseestraße wird zum symbol für eine
bessere sozialistische ddr
er spaziert auf dem dorotheenstädtischen
friedhof gleich um die ecke besucht die
gräber von brecht weigel und anderen
geistesgrößen verneigt sich vor ihnen
hier will auch biermann die letzte ruhe
finden
wie nahe sind uns man den tod
bedroht sind uns manche die lehman-krise
warum damit ich mich nicht zu tode
langweilen wenn ich tot bin noch ist es
nicht soweit noch redet er den mächtigen
ins gewissen und wie steht es um ost und
west in unserem land es ist aber nicht
die ostdeutschen haben zwei diktaturen
nennt als ich das mache riesige
unterschiede
im ganzen gefühlshaushalt eines menschen
in dem was er denkt und was er fühlt
die carus mit grundschulen 11
dem tun seine arme sowie
gott sei dank gibt es passende playlists
oder noch besser passende scheibe
nirgendwo sie können hier gleich die
verleihung des deutschen zukunftspreises
von heute abend nach erleben
bundespräsident steinmeier überreicht
gewonnen hat ihn das team um smtp und
ursachen für die entwicklung eines m rna
impfstoffes und ebenso spannend sind die
forschenden aus münster die mit
kautschuk aus löwenzahn reifen
herstellen oder die aus erlangen mit
einem kristall der in der
computertomografie viel schärfere bilder
liefert bei viel geringer
strahlenbelastung das zu sehen macht
freude bleiben sie also bei uns und wir
verabschieden uns für heute sein amt bis
morgen
[Musik]
guten abend darf ich vorstellen das ist
tief ulrich seine kaltfront show beute
die hochnebeldecke über mitteleuropa ein
bisschen zusammen einige von ihnen
konnten so die sonne sehen es gibt
allerdings gleich wieder das nächste
tief nach dem tief ulrich kommt nämlich
dass die folge heran und das bringt uns
morgen auch wieder etwas regen das ist
dann eine ganz schwache warmfront im
ergebnis sieht das ganz ähnlich aus es
regnet ein bisschen und es gibt wieder
ein neues hoch nämlich valentina und das
breitet sich aus das führt dann dazu
dass es morgen im südwesten deutschlands
mal häufiger auch ein bisschen
sonnenschein gibt die gute nachricht für
das zentrale mittelmeer ist dass dieses
tief wenigstens vorübergehend mal
deutlich schwächelt heute gab es ja noch
kräftige gewitter in sizilien oder auch
in apulien heute nacht ist es meist
trocken nur an den küsten gibt es einige
regenschauer und ein bisschen
nieselregen sonst ist es neblig und nach
wie vor bildet sich auch neuer
bodennebel an der nordseeküste sinken
die temperaturen acht bis 6 grad sonst
geht's auf 5 bis 3 grad runter am
kältesten wird an den alpen und morgen
liegen die temperaturen zwischen 5 und
12 grad am mildesten wird es an der
küste das liegt an dem starken zum teil
sogar stürmischen west südwest wind der
bringt die regenwolken von dem nächsten
tief folge heran sonst es ist häufig
trüb aber die sonnen anteile nehmen zum
beispiel hier in sachsen aber auch im
westen und am alpenrand und in den
nächsten tagen geht es ganz ähnlich
weiter erst später sinken die
temperaturen am sonntag auf vier bis elf
grad guten abend